so welcoming back everyone
good to see everyone here again
so um
uh
so today we have uh sean paul grant um
uh who um
from from penn state university he's
also uh visiting the science institute
this year
uh as a senior visitor
so sean uh for the longest time has been
work you know he's been working on
quantum algorithms ever since his phd
which
which finished in 2000
so he um
you know he has for example algorithms
for pals equation quantum algorithms of
health equation which breaks the buckmin
williams cryptosystem
for the unit group of the number field
and and he also has a lot of extra a lot
of work on
um you know non-appealing quantum
fourier transform and
you know the possibilities as well as
the limits of what that can do so today
he'll tell us about
um
about
some work he's done with leo elder on on
certain kinds of lattice problems that
you can you can solve using quantum
algorithms and afterwards we have a we
have a
uh we have a panel where we'll talk
about both uh well there are two things
to think through you know what to what
extent can these results be uh
replicated classically as well as
what are the implications so
yeah okay so i'll turn it over to sean
thank you
say
i assume you can see my screen now
okay so today you know i'm going to talk
about quantum algorithms like mesh said
i've been working on quantum algorithms
for a long time and i'm always
trying to find problems where we can get
good speed ups
um a lot of problems have been there
kind of since the beginning we've been
trying to to get somewhere
on them
uh but first let me say a little bit
about um
some of the things we know about
exponential speedups before getting into
lattices so of course this you know
there are exponential speed ups with
oracle problems and non-oracle problems
so here i'm talking about the non-oracle
problem versions um starting with shores
algorithm for factoring in discrete log
and as we know that
you know once you can solve those
problems you can break some related
cryptosystems and then we started
thinking about lattice problems graph
isomorphism
uh how can these
system you know
what can be done
and
let's see do i need to read chats
and then
okay i'm having a little bit someday
okay um
and then in 2002
we found another exponential speed up
for a number theory problem hell's
equation
and
there are some associated problems with
that in
this was in real quadratic number fields
uh principal ideal problem and computing
the class group it turned out that there
was also a
crypto system built on this uh the
bachmann williams key exchange system
and
there original motivation was
you know i guess the story is that when
the number field
was discovered it was a big surprise
that the running time had gone from
exponential to sub-exponential
and so they wanted to build a system
that could still be
maybe still unbreakable even if
factoring turns out to be in polynomial
time classically
but you know it is relying on the
hardness of powell's equation so that
that gets broken
and then
later on we generalized this to
computing the unit group of a n
dimensional
number field so here you can start
thinking about lattices
some of the lattices in crypto today are
based on number of fields power of two
cycle atomics
and um you know so we had stopped at the
number field and then
uh song and biasi extended it to the
unit group and then there was another
paper so there's sort of one piece
missing
where if you
can solve bdd in the unit group this is
by cdpr
then you can compute
approximate shortest vectors in these
lattices so they're the approximation
factors 2 to the square root n with an
efficient quantum algorithm
so that was sort of the first
sub-exponential approximation factor it
was for a special case of lattices that
have a lot a lot of algebraic structure
structure
and the algorithm is pretty complicated
um and then there were speed ups for
other other number theoretic problems
like function fields and other class
fields
but you know so we're going to go back
to lattices in this talk and try again
um
so you know lattices have been around
for a long time they originally have
applications factoring rational
polynomials back in the 80s and
computing approximate shortest vectors
but in the last 20 years um you know
lattice problems have become sort of the
most important hardness assumption in
post quantum crypto
um part of the you know so
part of that is sort of there's just
there are two things first of all you
have this very strong
theoretical
foundation which is that you have a
worst case average case reduction
either for the shortest vector or the
closest vector
which means that if you cannot solve
these worst-case lattice problems that
we've not been able to solve then you
also cannot break the cryptography
and so
um that's something to say that didn't
exist with factoring when factoring the
reduction is in the wrong direction
but
and then the second thing is that
especially for lwe the primitives are
it's so flexible you can just build
a lot of things that we could not build
before
so like fully homomorphic encryption
obfuscation
plastic trapdoor functions
classically and then it goes also into
quantum so testing quantumness
certifiable randomness
testing the machine is
is quantum so
um
a lot of things have become possible
because of
the the lattices um
and you know they're sort of very unique
in this sense of the flexibility and the
theoretical guarantee that underlies
their hardness
okay so i guess you know
i don't know if you need to say this
it's vital that we investigate whether
or not there are efficient algorithms to
solve these problems they could be
classical algorithms it could be quantum
algorithms
but we need to try and find some way to
say something about the hardness or to
make progress or you know to understand
more than what we've known
say since the 80s or
you know there have been some
improvements after that but they're
still similar
okay so
um there are two possibilities here so
one is we could try and work on the
underlying hardness assumptions this is
what i focused on because i'm just you
know for me complexity lattices you know
we have these well-defined problems want
to find an algorithm for them
if we break the worst case assumptions
the cryptosystems still could be secure
um you know when they pick parameters
for cryptosystems they can't use the
worst case assumptions they don't know
what a worst case lattice looks like so
it's it's a separate practical problem
but for the theoretical guarantee and
connection we need to know whether or
not the worst case problems are hard
you know the second option would be to
also
break the cryptosystems for certain
parameters
okay so today i'm going to show you
about uh
efficient quantum algorithm that leo and
i have been working on for certain
parameter ranges of lattices
so we're trying to take some step and
identify you know sort of partition
lattices in a way so that we can
identify maybe pieces where we can try
and make steps
okay so we're going to use properties
from cryptography so a lot of nice
theories there just with random q area
lattices or q periodic lattices
and
so the classical complexity of the
lattice problem we solve you know this
is this can be up for discussion i'm not
going to claim of course that there's no
classical algorithm we don't know
um
you know so we might have an exponential
speed up uh or maybe we're only
presenting a perspective on lattices
where you can sort of now start to pick
apart classes and try and solve separate
classes but as far as i know right now
there's no there's no classical
algorithm the best one would be to use
schnoor's bkz that runs in
sub-exponential time
all
right we're going to talk about lattice
problems
there are two main lattice problems
so a lattice and a lattice you're given
a set of vectors so today everything is
going to be over the integers so
you're given a set of
vectors
and
you
you define a set of all linear
combinations of those to be
a lattice so here say you're given b1
and b2 in two dimensions
then you know these thoughts you have
infinite in two dimensions
uh number of points in the lattice
and these problems are hard in high
dimensions you can solve them in low
dimensions so the first problem is
called
you want to compute the shortest vector
so in this picture that would be the
the green circled lattice vector not the
origin the origin is always in the lines
but we all know that so the shortest
non-zero vector
and typically the bases are there an
infinite number of bases that you can be
given for a lattice and
you know you can be given they're given
to you think of in a very skewed form so
even though we can see the shortest
vector here on the picture when you're
given these vectors you don't really
know how to find them
and the second problem which is the one
we're going to talk about today is that
you're given an extra target vector
t
which is not appearing
but it's somewhere up around the lattice
and you want to compute the closest
lattice vector to t
okay now these problems are mp hard in
general
so
we don't expect polynomial time
algorithms we make restrictions to them
for crypto or to try and find algorithms
and today we'll look at this common
case called bounded distance decoding
invalid distance decoding the target
vector you can think of it as being
really close to the lattice point
so for example if s down here is the
lattice is the closest lattice point and
t is your target vector you're
guaranteed
that you're sort of exponentially close
this is sorry well this is where we
already know there's an algorithm so
from ll and bye bye
in the 80s there's an efficient
classical algorithm of course to con to
solve bdd
when you're exponentially close
i'm going to be using fractions maybe
for some approximation factors like i'll
be saying 1 over 2 to the n but if
you're familiar with lattices what that
means is that the
the distance is within the shortest
vector lengths divided by 2 to the n oh
i have okay
that should be lambda over 2 to the n
not lambda over 2 to the minus m
but you measure it as a fraction of the
shortest vector length okay so when it's
if you're with exponentially close
efficient classical algorithm
we're going to actually use this in our
algorithm
and and today
our goal is to get to a sub-exponential
range
so if your lattice has dimension n
we want to try and be able to solve it
when your vector is within 1 over 2 say
you know 1 over 2 to the squared with m
so we're trying to move from the
exponential domain
down to the sub-exponential domain
title's gone
okay
uh pulling so you know our starting
point we can pull a lot of what's known
from crypto already
and and use that
and for the purposes of the talk i'll
i'm going to
use a special case
lattice to simplify how i describe
everything and so
what we know from crypto is you can take
what are called q periodic lattices or q
area lattices
that repeat
on each axis
mod q so like in the picture on the
x-axis there's the q and then there's a
lattice point on the y-axis there's a q
lattice point
what that means is the lattice just
exactly has exact copies of itself
and if you restrict to this finite cube
you have all the information you need
about the lattice
now to
the specific case we'll consider in this
setting is we'll take just one generator
b
so say this is vector v it's an
n-dimensional lattice
and to define it here you just take all
multiples of b
and
even though lattices are infinite i'm
going to say lattice for the rest of the
talk even though we're working we're
going to work mod q
and i mean lattice points
okay so the question is going to be the
same as before we're going to be given a
target vector that is close to a lattice
point so this target vector t
we think of s as being a secret vector
it's just unknown but we'll use s for
secret
and we want to compute the multiple of
the basis vector b that gives us the
lattice
the the closest lattice point
and if you're familiar with the hidden
number problem this is actually
a worst case version of the hidden
number problem
the hidden number problem you're given
the high order bits
of
s mod different numbers
and you try and compute
s from that
in that case you assume
that the vector b here would be
uniformly random and then there's an
algorithm that you can where you can
solve it here we're going to take a
worst case vector b rather than a
uniformly random b
[Music]
okay
so here's a high level view of where
we're going
so we want to try and get a 2 to the n
approximation
okay for this problem we're given a
lattice as i described
on the previous slide it's multiples of
a vector inside the q cube
and
so the lattice problem itself here i'm
back up in the integers on the right
hand side
this is the lattice that would be
defined and the close vector that you're
given we'll use a quantum algorithm
to generate samples
just basically to map it to a lower
dimensional space so we'll start an
n-dimensional space up top
and we'll map down to square root
n-dimensional space
in a new lattice
the the key will be that the new lattice
is a random lattice and it preserves the
guarantee from the original lattice
and if we can do that
then we can use the classical algorithms
once you can match the dimension and
once your
distance is two to the dimension
you use classical algorithms
okay
this is a sort of
draft one of my slides so if you see
typos like 2 to the i times square root
of n in the bottom there
it's just the minus sign should be
outside the square root of not inside
sorry about that
so
our algorithm is going to use you know
known random lattice properties that
have been developed in crypto
um
and the main thing the quantum is going
to do the quantum subroutine is it's
going to take this worst case instance
at the top
map it to a random instance of lower
dimension in the bottom
it's going to preserve
q the periodicity
and it's going to preserve the
approximation factor up to some
polynomial factors which won't matter
since we're in a sub-exponential range
okay so i want to move on to the the
quantum algorithm how do we reduce to a
lower dimension how do we generate these
samples
and
i'm going to call this sort of the
standard approach for those of us who've
been working on this for a long time
there's something we've always tried
and we're going to start the same way
and i'll show you where we get stuck
usually and
what we do next
okay so we're working our problem now is
combined confined to this finite cube on
the right so we we can create
superpositions over this very easily
so the the superposition here you know
if you have two registers you could
compute the fourier transform in the
first register
have a superposition over coefficients
then you could
uh you can compute the actual lattice
vector into the second register
that's the multiple of that vector we
had and everything is mod q
here and then when it's possible if you
want you can uncompute the the
coefficient register and then you just
have a straight
uh superposition over lattice points in
the cube it could be that you know if if
q is a prime you can do this
if it's not a prime you can't do this
all the time but it doesn't impact what
we do
so the bottom
line is a superposition over lattice
points
and once you have this you know you
start playing with it and you see that
uh it's an eigenvector of shift by
measure
sorry okay so two things you know
one is
you you don't mean you can uncompute c
in general right so
right when possible yeah one possible as
long as it's invertible as long as it's
a one-to-one function
you can
it's just an integer
multiple
if you have zero divisors then you can't
because it's not a one-to-one function
okay so the first property you notice
when we play with this is that it's a
it's a one eigenvector of shift by group
elements so in general if you add a
a vector to superposition say we have
some superposition over x and we add a
vector y uh it's just sickly cyclically
or not cyclic it shifts it relative to
the group structure here the underlying
group is
uh integers mod q
in in n dimensions
and so if we were to add a group
element say d times that vector b
then we would get back the original
state as you can see along the bottom so
you just collect coefficients then you
re-index your superposition because it's
a permutation when you get back to the
lattice
you must have another question
sorry um
i mean okay maybe maybe we are
you're saying something different but of
course when you're on compute you you
would get interference so don't you want
to do a fourier transform there or
something to and compute or
no this is this isn't there's no there's
no box around the lattice points yet
these are just these are just the
lattice points so it's okay
guys
okay so this is a basic property it's in
variant under shift oh man okay my
builds are also a little wacky right now
so
now we want to consider what happens if
we you know we're given this target
vector v our t sorry that's not a not a
one eigenvector it's not in the lattice
and you try and shift by that instead
and see what happens
so
you know on the first line and repeating
from the previous slide you have a one
eigenvector but we have t
that's what's given a point close to a
lattice point and if you shift by that
you know it's close to the lattice
so it's a it's a lattice point s times b
but there's some error vector delta
there
and when you add there you end when you
add t you end up orthogonal to the
original superposition and that's not
that's not helpful
you can't you know
at least if you're just experimenting
with properties you run out of things to
do
so the fix to this is to put a
superposition
cube around each point
okay so here on the bottom left i've
john say there's there's the lattice
point cb
the box means there's a superposition
around that point
and then if you shift by some amount
there's still a lot of overlap and it
behaves kind of like the one eigenvector
did
okay so if you shift by t you have first
the the one eigenvalue part s times b
which goes away
and then you have the small vector delta
which is still sitting there and it's
it's messing up your super position but
you still still behave similarly
okay so if this were our goal
to compute this superposition over
lattice points with boxes around each
one it would look like the superposition
at the bottom right
we would have a sum over coefficient c
and then a sum over
elements in the cube
and then we would have
lattice vector c times e plus the cue
point
or if you like convolution this is
taking the lattice and convolving it
with a box
but um creating this data's challenge so
what happens so
here's what happens when you try and do
it
you know you can create this i'll start
calling it a box so i can write box in
the cat so it's there's less
different notation but if you want to
put a box around the point
you just compute the fourier transform
in a different register so if you look
at the second
line you can have lattice coefficients
you have your cube coefficients
then you add the first register into the
second register
and that's almost what we need but
from the if you look on the right from
the previous slide what we need is that
first register to be a zero and here we
you know when we tried to create this
superposition on the left we're stuck
with the coefficient there
so the first the two the two registers
are entangled
unless there's a way for me to point or
if i should point but
the two registers are entangled you can
use your mouse to point clicking let's
see i don't see my mouse right now
[Music]
so you get into this sort of dangerous
situation where
if you want to create
if you wanted to erase that coefficient
and create the statement that we want
you'd have to solve
boundary distance equation
okay because if you can solve boundary
distance decoding you can take bounded
distance decoding on l and the argument
in the second register which is you know
one of these box elements around the
lattice point you get the coefficient
associated with it
and then you erase the first register
but this is a circular argument the
problem we're trying to solve is
boundary distance decoding so if we use
bound distance we can't use it to solve
and solve this this problem
um
now
regev in o5
when he was doing lwe
he got here and he sort of you know as
far as i'm concerned he turned lemons
into some very good lemonade
he knew he wanted to get rid of that
point and you know so he came up with
this this complicated iterative instruct
construction where if you call
lwe which is a which is a bdd instance
you can use it to
compute short vectors
to get this reduction
um but
but when you're trying to find an
algorithm for the problem it's it's
still there it's still a problem
hi sean
yeah there is a question in the chat can
you state the size of q with respect to
n it'll be exponential we want to have a
sub exponential approximation factor so
q has to be at least that
so sub exponential or an exponential
yes this is different parameter range
than lwe lwe if you use polynomial q
then
there aren't you know it's
sub-exponential approximation factor
doesn't have any non-trivial instances
[Music]
okay so let's try and get try you know
and think about algorithms though you
know we can go back and say okay
lattices are a billion groups
and quantum algorithms have been really
good with using ability groups
uh what can we do
so the standard approach you know this
is continuing the standard approach i
was talking about before what do you do
so we have this entangled state on the
first line
the first two registers are entangled
we'd like to get rid of that c in the
first register to unentangle it
and so what people kind of do is you
throw up your hands and say okay i'm
going to compute the fourier transform
of the first register and
then i'll measure the result
to simplify the state
and then i'll end up with the third line
this is kind of like what i showed you
we would like to have
except there's this phase in there
this phase is omega to the ac mod q
where c is the coefficient of the
lattice vector
and a is now just a randomly selected
number because in line two we measured
that register and got a random a
and if you try and use the fourier
transform at this point it becomes a
mess because
this phase it's very hard to analyze you
don't know what you get
okay so today what we'll do is continue
from here and say okay well you know
phases there are cases when phases are
good and there are you know this is an
abelian group
so today
you know bottom half of the slide will
continue from here
um if we start with this superposition
with the phases in it
let's try and use the phase in a
different way
um
so for notation let's let's think about
so let's think about what this state is
if we call the second part of that
superposition
like just a box around the vector
c sub b
then what we have is a superposition
over lattice points
with a box around each lattice point
and each of those boxes has a single
phase so it's kind of like the picture
on the right you have these green these
green superposition boxes are on each
point and each one has a phase
so from this point of view
um you know we could go back and ask
okay is it still an eigenvector of a
group shift
so on the bottom line here
suppose we add a vector
s times b
from the n-dimensional lattice
so what you get is you know in the left
equation you have the vector c b plus c
s
and since it's over a group you can
reindex it and when you re-index it you
pop out an eigenvalue
whose
phase is
minus a times s over q
now here a was random
and s gives us the identity of the shift
right the shift was by a vector s times
b
and the coefficient s is sitting there
in the face
and we have a quant you know there's one
of the main quantum primitives is
quantum eigenvalue estimation where you
can
take an eigenvector like this and you
can compute what's in the phase
so if we had access you know if we
didn't know s and we could shift by s we
could run quantum eigenvalue estimation
and compute s and that would be the
answer
the problem is we don't actually have
this is not our setup our setup is a
little bit different where we had
this target vector instead of the secret
vector
okay
so we have this state on the first line
it's a superposition
[Music]
uh
okay that s should not be in there on
the first line
we just have the box around each lattice
point with the phase and we have this
target vector t that we know is a
lattice point s times b plus
some small shift delta
we know that the state is an eigenvector
of shifting by a group element say s
times p
but it's not an eigenvector of t
what we're going to do is shift by t
because that's all we have right
and
the the point is going to be that
if you shift by t
you're you know you can think of it as
first shifting by the lattice vector s
times b
in which case you'll pop out that
eigenvalue that has the identity of s
there it's omega to the a times s
plus some
term delta that's gonna take the
eigenvector and mess it up it's gonna
it's gonna shift
so
i think i have let me see if this is the
right slide
okay
somehow my slide got
damaged when i was carrying it
to my talk
um
[Music]
so what this picture is supposed to
represent is you start with uh the first
superposition one one of the cubes okay
so here are two lattice points on the
screen
there's a there's there's a cube around
each one
and then if you apply shift by t you'll
pop out the eigenvalue and then that the
overlapping one is overlapping it's over
it's shifted by delta
okay and delta is our bdd guarantee it's
something like lambda over 2 to the
square root of n
so this gives us
what we call an approximate eigenvector
it's not an eigenvector it still has it
still has the right phase just the right
eigenvalue coming out
but the the eigenvector slowly decays as
you apply more and more powers to it it
overlaps less and less so you get less
signal from it
and so the upshot is that if you apply
phase estimation on this
you can go up to
power around
two to the square root of m
before before just you know before it's
gone before the boxes don't overlap
anymore
so without if you're
if you're guarantees you're within one
over two square root n you can compute
that power
since you're going up to a limited power
the quantum phase estimation is not
going to
give you
the full value of s but it will give you
a value it'll give you
square root n bits of it
okay so
what you get is
you'll get s times a so you want to find
s a is random you get s times a and
another value
it will you
called h okay so on the ith sample you
get a i and h i
that are within q over two to the square
root n
so so far what happened is that you
started from sort of n samples of the
hidden number problem let's say right
and you keep generating more and more
samples random samples right that's uh
that's what's going on
yeah
yeah
and arbitrary samples to
square them random samples
so depending on which number problem you
know if the hidden number problem is
defined as
random samples then it's not that
because we're starting with the
arbitrary
vector b
and then
so i don't know if there's a definition
for worst case of another problem but
that's that's kind of what it's like
okay
so this is this is the basic thing we
get we get
a i hi
with this guarantee
q over
the original approximation factor and
i'm simplifying things there are like
polynomial factors and there are some
exponents it might be 2 to the
2 square root n or 4 square root n or
something i'm just sort of
keeping it simple
that's the idea of how the
numbers tie together
okay so if we go back to the overview
slide
i just described
an algorithm a quantum subroutine that
would generate these samples
and i use different notation but
you get b tildes you get a b tilde bi
tilde ti tilde
and each time you run it you get a new
sample and you stack it you stack them
into this bottom matrix
to get a random matrix
row by row in that bottom matrix they
satisfy the closeness guarantee
and therefore the whole vector is at
most
you know square root of the dimension
times that guarantee which is small
and so you end up turning a worst case
bdd instance on top into a random bdd
instance
where
the new dimension matches
the dimension the approximation factor
where it can be classically solved
so classically
using device algorithm for approximate
closest vector
if your guarantee is that you're within
1 over 2 to the dimension
then there's an efficient algorithm and
down here dimension square root n
approximation factor square of 2 to the
square root n so that matches and we
apply the classical algorithm
now here there's a question you can ask
and we've kind of been asking
which is can you do this classically
right we have this quantum subroutine
that takes a worst case lagos on top
generates a random lattice on the bottom
with the same guarantees
can you do it classically
can you just take say a random subset of
the rows i mean all we're doing is
reducing the dimension which is a little
bit counter-intuitive
but the key is we're adding randomness
so
could you take a random subset of the
rows on top
so that you're in dimension square with
n
and you know
could you still guaran the main thing we
need at the bottom is a long shortest
vector would you get a long shortest
vector
you have a question
yeah um yeah so i was wondering why is
your dimension why does your dimension
go down to square root n does it it
seems from what you said that you can
just generate as many samples as you
want each time you start from the
beginning and you generate a sample
so why why can you only generate like
square root n of those or no you can
generate as many as you want but like if
you generate n
then you're sort of back into the
i know there's different ways to look at
it so you can generate as many as you
want but you only you you purposely just
want square root n of those yeah that's
the sweet spot for
okay that's really the biggest that's
where you have the biggest decoding
radius no yeah i thought maybe the decay
had to do with it but the decay only has
to do with like the noise level
yeah
[Music]
okay
thank you so yeah so there's this
question of whether this can just be
done classical i don't know
sorry sean um how many phase estimations
were you running was it one for every
b tilde row of utility
yes one for each
one for each row in the matrix
i see how do you deal with the like
correctness of phase estimation
um
well we define the notion of an
approximate eigenvector we say if you
have a pair of a unitary and a vector
so that when you apply them
[Music]
uh and you consider what it would be if
it was an eigenvector so i didn't write
it down unfortunately because i ran out
of time but
you know if you're within some epsilon
if it's if it's almost acting like an
eigenvector epsilon you can just analyze
phase estimation and say if you go up to
some power t
the resulting state you get is within t
times epsilon
and then
[Music]
that's the basic idea so
uh sure but isn't the guarantee of phase
estimation that you're within that bound
with some probability like how do you
handle that that outside failure
probability
failure probability is
uh you can just choose a union balance
so here we're here we're picking like
square root and samples
so you can pick your failure probability
and phase estimation to be
you know 1 over
2 square root n or 1 over n or something
i see so in total you're doing like root
n phase estimations and each one of
those is costing like two to the root n
time
not two to the root n time it's a
superposition over two to the root n
items
it's a polynomial time
right okay
[Music]
did you have a higher time calculation
[Music]
uh i mean i just missed something then
um but like i guess i'm having trouble
seeing what the current run time is
oh
well if you think of if you think of q
as an exponential you can run in time
polynomial and log q
right so if q is like two to the n
say
sorry so so just just if i can cut into
a moment so so firmly i think he's
saying that if you're if you're raising
your operator to pop two to the m in
your phase estimation up to two to the m
it takes you m time right so that's
that's
sorry sorry you you just need to
no no
yeah that's right that's um
i mean if you think of something like
factoring when you do phase estimation
you know you compute to some
giant exponential power
because it runs in time log of that
and
this is
you know so the
order of the the magnitude of the
numbers is the same
in the sense that you need to go up to q
in superposition so that's log q bits
i see are you using the fact that like
for this particular operator computing
like the exponents of this is easy
yes definitely okay sorry i was uh yeah
no that's very important yes for phase
estimation when you apply an operator
you have to make sure you can you have
to take into account how hard it is to
iterate
yep okay good i see and iterating i'll
just say for everybody so iterating
multiple you know you're adding t many
times so that means you're taking a
multiple of t
which you can do with repeated squaring
so you can calculate u to the to q
in time log q
thank you
that's great
yes
um so sean uh you know another way to
sort of uh um get more samples um
of hearing number is to pick random
subsets of uh what you have
uh and add them up right so that'll
increase the error but only a tiny bit
you know so it doesn't really matter and
the question of whether you it does
randomize the coefficients related to
the sort of the minimum distance of the
lattice and actually the minimum
distance of the nth minimum distance of
the dual uh the minimum distance is very
large here so the nth minimum is very
small in the dual so you should be able
to sort of like you know maybe not zero
one coefficients but um
you know um
um you know smallish coefficients um
should work so so
um so is there something you know that
i'm missing here is there something that
the classical sort of procedure will not
do that uh
the quantum thing does um
well it depends if what you just said is
a proof or a heuristic or a gas i mean i
don't know believe it's a proof but uh
but we can sort of take it offline and
we can also handle more vectors so you
know i'm giving one is the vector so
maybe you can think about whether if you
have
k vectors instead of one vector b
can you also do that classically then
you're sampling inner products instead
of just multiples
well then it depends on k actually like
how uh you know how the procedure sort
of decays with k and so forth
well maybe you can think about if you
can get up to a square root n so that's
that's maybe where we're heading yeah
that's yeah
real
lattice algorithms here
solving
sorry sean just from my understanding
like is what you just clarified to me
sort of that sort of feels like the key
observation right that
you guys observe that uh it suffices to
apply phase estimation for a particular
operator and this operator is like some
addition operator for which like
uh computing the exponents of this is
easy and
is that the source of the speed up
well the observation i think was at
least from what we knew before was that
this you can use this as an eigenvector
you you can use phase estimation i mean
i don't know i'm trying to like
reconstruct history and see see what
happens and uh you know maybe people
were too focused on the fourier
transform
i don't know so i think i think just
once you start treating it as phase
estimation
then
yeah
you see what happens with the
approximate phase with you know phases
naively like phase estimation would take
a long time right but i think in your
particular case you're saying that the
operator for that you're trying to
estimate the phase of or with respect to
is easy to compute the exponents of this
operator right
yeah generally like if i have like some
unitary u and estimate phase with
respect to u like evaluating u to the
two to the t takes two to the t time and
you're saying this is fast because you
have a very special u
that's that's definitely true and that's
definitely important i think i don't
usually use views that are not like that
so for me i yeah maybe i'm just
i'm not as connected to the question but
you're right that is very important like
how much time it takes to iterate you to
high powers the exponential powers can
you do it in polynomial time
okay is there any other source of speed
up besides this fact that that u is easy
to compute the powers of
um i'm not sure what you mean by that
that's a classical operation but
do you mean the phase estimation
uh no no like that you can run i mean
the quantum algorithms run time depends
on how long it takes you to compute the
powers of you
and so you're like does it i'm seeing
that here that the speed up comes from
the fact that
that this is true and the computing
powers of u is easy
uh is there any other source of the
algorithmic speed up
uh i don't know what i would describe as
the source of the algorithm speed up um
the algorithmic speed up comes from
having a
an eigenvector that that tells us what
you know what the shift is if you shift
by a lattice point and in this case we
are close to one and not close to one
i
i i'm not sure if i can phrase it the
way you're phrasing it
um yeah maybe speed up is the wrong term
um because
not comparing relative to anything but
it does seem like the non-trivial stuff
is that phase estimation solves your
problem and that this is a nice
application of phase estimation because
of the properties of the operator that's
true okay thanks
sean if you don't mind i think i missed
a step so um
you took your uh the superposition over
cubes
you shift it by
um uh multiples of t
and then you you run phase estimation to
get like square root n digits of uh
i guess the secret s
and then
not up to q i don't know if you said
superposition over q you take the
superposition up to like two to the
square root of n
oh over the cubes uh the cubes yes yes
um
i'm missing like and then how do you get
from
you know square root n digits of s to
these b tildes
oh you just write them down
so
if you think of um
i guess i changed notation here so in
the previous slide i was sampling a
random a
that random a is the bi tilde
the random ai is a bi tilde that's a
uniformly random integer not q
okay and then the sample you got the hi
i think i called it sorry about that is
now the ti
so you're really just
stacking let me see if i can go back and
see what i called it
yeah sorry about that so that the ai is
the the random
um
[Music]
lattice basis vector
the hi is the new target vector you just
stack these
one on top of the other
and row by row see this so the point is
that in all these setups is that
s times a i is in the lattice
and so that's your new secret vector you
keep the same coefficient as the
original problem but you have a
different lattice vector
a is a just a uniformly random
you just pick it at random and and yeah
that came from when we chose when we
computed the fourier transform to get
rid of the coefficient we just measured
that register so it's just uniformly
random oh i see
and and h is uh what again
that is the estimation for the phase
after you multiply by q around it you
know
you scale it and round it to the nearest
signature
got it okay thanks
hi sean um quick question so in the
addition when you shift
you are shifting by say t then to t then
40 80 and so on yes and you only do this
up to a power of two to the square root
n
so it's two to the square root of and
like the maximum you can shift these
cubes and still have polynomially large
overlap between them
yes
yeah it comes down to your approximation
factor because this uh the initial shift
i mean the initial guarantee this arrow
on the left sorry i left this out this
is like the error vector you start with
like lambda over two to the square root
of n
so once you multiply this say by two to
the square root n you're on top of the
next lattice vector right okay so i get
that constraint onto the square end but
how about the shift in say
extra phase d to delta because here you
are shifting by p rather than s of v so
when you say you shift by delta to the
two power squared and each of these
cubes can have a very different phase
that depends on delta
well if okay so let me try and
answer it so so in general we're taking
k times t
for an integer k
right right so that's uh k times sv but
sb gives you an eigenvector
it's a power so you end up you end up
applying that that one k times and you
just pop out that eigenvalue to the k
power
and then all that's left is the k times
delta
so it's using the fact that the first
part of t
keeps wrapping back to the same place
does that make sense i mean it's um
maybe maybe try it with delta equals
zero and you see that you get powers of
omega to the s times a
so yeah
okay
i'll think about it thanks i think i'm
gonna think about it you know you're
asking these details
mainly i'm just worried that because
there's this phase that depends on delta
your overlap with the eigen state might
not be
um that of
like you know when you have an eigen
state of the addition operator
there are these faces like omega to the
a times s
but
if you have this additional delta
and then each of your lattice points has
this phase that depends on delta is that
still having strong overlap with this
eigenvector that has no alpha in it
uh i'm not sure i mean the cubes come
back to the same cubes as the way i'm
thinking about it okay yeah i'll think
about it thanks
sean one question about the previous
slide
um sorry the one with the b and the b
tildes yeah that's the one
so um i just trying to think about it in
terms of lwe uh which i you know kind of
have mostly ingrained in my brain
um
if you think about the
target uh how far off each coordinate of
the target is from
um s times b i right so what's the
difference between t i and s times b i
uh
relative to q
um
and then similarly what's the difference
between
the
uh i guess it's the hi or the the tilde
the
random target
and the corresponding um
ai
relative to q can can you
shed some light on the
there are relationships there are some
small powers like so i wrote up top here
the distances at most 2 to the minus 4
square we're done
in the top
or maybe it's a minus 6 square root n or
something and then on the bottom
there's like a polynomial factor oh and
it's square root so our error instead of
being
instead of having the same approximation
factor times something we have square
root of the approximation factor
so if you start say if you start with
that 4 it would become a 2 to the minus
2 square root of n
[Music]
and then there's a polynomial factor to
handle so
you know
yeah the polynomial factors i don't
really care about but i guess what i'm
trying to get at is
um
the distance between the target and the
lattice point
uh is is is like 2 to the minus root n
times q is that right
oh well oh sorry yeah it's actually
lambda 1 times that i left lambda out
you're biased yeah i i i kind of thought
so but um
so it's it's like two to the minus root
n times q
yeah
and it's similarly
roughly two to the minus root n times q
in the average case elements that you
produce as well
yes square root of that
times polynomials
square root of that okay the
approximation factor
i see so it's um because
i guess larger than or yes it becomes
larger larger okay
okay
i see okay uh but then so even though
like the error terms are larger in the
average case instance
the fact that you
uh
only produce square root n of these
terms somehow helps you solve it faster
yeah we're just picking the dimension
like if you start at n we know we want
to end up at square root of n
and then you choose the approximation
factor and q so that those exponents
work out
i guess i'm just wondering i'm having
trouble seeing why you can't solve the
original problem
classically just by taking a random
subset of the rows or something like
that just by just ignoring a lot of the
rows and right just yeah using the ones
you pick
yeah that's the that's that's a question
right now that's what vinod was
suggesting earlier if you have a worst
case vector there or more vectors what
happens to
i mean because you know most lattices up
top have long longest long shortest
vector to begin with and sure
furthermore for this to be non-trivial
we have to pick one of those ones that
has
a shortest vector that's at least the
approximation factor of course the
inverse of the approximation factor
so you know something about where you're
starting with is a parameter restriction
and
it could be the counting of something
you know you end up or maybe even
already has the proof that
a subset will still have a longest a
long enough short vector in the bottom
because that's the point of the
randomness in the bottom is to have a
long short vector
i thought it can be solved classically
but you know
i think he was suggesting
maybe doing
random sums of the rows uh of the top
element but i'm
yeah i'm saying it's like just a random
subset of the rose or something well you
could try either
right
um so so chris if i may uh random
substance is like the first sort of
thought right but it could sort of end
up happening that uh if you pick around
you pick some subset right uh
that could have uh unreasonably short
vector uh but in any case i think you
know you can you know maybe maybe
already picking a random subset will
sort of make sure that it doesn't have
an unreasonably short vector i don't
know right that would be the
i don't know it seems like maybe likely
or possible that it wouldn't yeah
well you have you okay so um let me let
me just say um
you know uh sean you shouldn't worry
about time will oh
because we have a lot of experts here so
uh it's fine to keep answering these
questions and you know it would be good
for you to finish the talk so we'll
we'll think of this as the panels
already started sort of informally for a
little bit and then you go back to your
talking so okay so let me say a few more
things then to finish the talk since i
didn't realize that the time had slipped
by
um just to maybe provoke some more
questions and then um all right so the
question here is like you know what have
we solved we're talking about this one
vector and so on and
how do we how do you think about this
um
i'm trying to adjust my screen here
sorry one second
um so
you know so far we focused on a vector b
q times the identity this is uh what
we've been calling the k equals one case
uh when we're talking about it we are
and i
so let's take an arbitrary lattice now
in dimensions with periosteum
periodicity q
okay so what we want to do is take all
lattices partition them and say like
okay these are the ones we're working on
right now and trying to understand what
the complexity is
so because q
is the q periodicity um because of the q
periodicity if you take the lattice mod
q
it's a finite abelian group you
decompose it into some cyclic factors
eq1 up to z2k so here k is
you know we've been dealing with one
cyclic factor now let's say case of clip
factors
so we have a picture i was hoping to
film this picture by today but er and i
are like lost in five dimensional space
with all these parameters and then i had
to try and pop out of that and make
slides
um
so okay partition all lattices by nqk k
is the number of cyclic factors in l mod
q
so we pick a dimension we pick a
periodicity you pick the finite group
rank you get there and then you try and
figure out what approximation factors
you can solve coming out in the next
dimension
this is sort of the general approach to
try and understand how to think about
lattices
so i'm going to have to double check
these bounds i was putting them in the
last second um
but in this setup uh i think
what we get is when q is like let's go
back to square root n let's say it's 2
to the
n over k
instead of 2 to the q being 2 to the n
it's 2 to the n over k you get an
approximation factor like
1 over 2 to the square root n over k
that might not be quite right
i have to double check that
but i can maybe reconstruct it for while
we're having the pound
or where it can help me with that
in general
um
oh yeah
oh boy so it's already an hour i'm sorry
about that
um it's it's fine you can keep you know
we have a panel so we we can think of we
spend ten minutes let me just sort of
run through these so i'll say that
partly what we have is this this
worst-case average case reduction it's
like a self-reduction from worst case
bdd to random case bbd that reduction
works even for smaller polynomial you
know smaller approximation factors like
polynomial
but when we do it you know when we pop
out the new instance we don't know how
to solve it we're targeting the range in
this talk where we know there's a
classical algorithm that can solve it
um okay there's a relation to ship to
lwe parameters which i won't go through
now it's pretty confusing um we can talk
about that how do you compare this to
sort of all of that
um
and then just conclusion so we we have
this algorithm maybe it's classical
maybe it's fun for
bounded distance decoding worst case
for sub-exponential approximation
factors within you know some parameters
i will say that
when you look at the algorithm you look
what you have i think there are a lot of
more things you can try here you can try
and create other superpositions related
to this you can you know i think there's
a lot to play with here it's like a big
playground for us
um and you can try the parameter ranges
now that we have sort of have this
mapped out
in general i would like to ask what is
the right approximation factor for
intermediate steps of these algorithms
so something i hid here
i sort of thought you know the actual
thing that happens when you take one of
these partitions of nkq is
you map from dimension n down to
dimension square root of k log q
i plugged in a special q and k to make
it sub exponential but there's a more
general phenomenon there and i'm
wondering
what should the right you know should
the approximation factor always just be
a function of n is that the only thing
we care about or or should you you know
because the dimension and the volume of
the lattice can grow independently and
how do we you know what's the right way
to think about that
i don't know
and finally there are these really nice
classical transformations for lwe i'm
using random bdd because that's how i'm
thinking about it but you know lwe is an
instance of that where they change the
parameters they can go from polynomial
parameters
to say
one dimension and an exponentially large
q
now that q becomes really large i think
it's at least 2 to the n squared so it's
out of our range
but maybe these classical
transformations could get into a range
where a quantum algorithm can also solve
it
okay so that's my talk thank you
great thank you
so um
there seem to be a number of questions
um
[Music]
shall we just have um
i think noah had a question do you want
to just ask
should i read it
yeah yeah okay so so maybe i'll read it
all right so yeah i can read it
um
okay i'm mentioning that it's worst case
average case
does it matter that we get an average
case problem at the end there the answer
is yes because we need the long short
vector
to be a bdd instance
and then it says it seems like you're
just using a worst case lattice
algorithm at the end of the day that's
true the big thing is that yes the big
thing is the dimension reduction to a
random lattice
so that's that's some
bad question for nora he doesn't have a
follow-up
so i didn't understand the answer
um you're saying that
what why you needed to be ever
why an average lattice i'm not sure i
thought it is a worst case algorithm
that you are using
yes but but the quantum algorithm
outputs a random instance
and the random cases
are ones we know we can solve
so but it does it on a lower dimension
too so so really what you want is for
lambda one to sort of decay the way that
you want it to right so you go from a
large dimension to a small dimension and
who knows what happens if you do it
arbitrarily so the the average case
thing sort of helps you to say well for
average case um you know for average
case instances of this dimension i know
what the shortest vector is going to
look like
the length of the shortest vector is
going to be so this is sort of the
reason why you need the average case
yeah we're heavily leaning on these
properties from crypto
where the qari lattices are you know
very nice results on exactly how long
the shortest spectre is within a
constant
of minkowski's box so it's it's
gives us a lot of
but it is plausible that what uh chris
and you know we're saying that even
taking a sub-sample
like on average will preserve this
quantity it's not um
it's not out of the question that it
will um
i mean yeah i i don't know i don't know
that it was that was analyzed no that's
a good question
i don't know what the answer is
i have more confidence and we can
increase k so we can have more vectors
also and see
so we sort of run out of room around k
equals square root n
i think so you know if you can do it
classically can you do it up to k
because to square down
vectors in the n-dimensional lattice
space
to begin with
um
[Music]
it says hand-raised do you want to speak
uh just a quick question what was the
largest value of lambda you could assume
here was it like uh 2 to the power of
minus square root n
lambda well sorry sorry not lambda and
then delta
oh sorry what was that oh delta
uh so like 2 to the n to the delta
you're saying
um
what's the largest value of delta you
use here 2 to the minus square root n
their delta is one half
that's just plugging in delta equals one
half is two plus two to the square root
of them
and then
[Music]
i think he means he meant capital
oh
delta
that's the approximation factor so
you're tying that
you're picking q and the approximation
factor to
[Music]
q and the approximation factor to
that
roughly or at least be within the icons
all right
okay so
maybe maybe let's move on to the
the panel uh so if uh
sean if you would stop sharing your
screen and then
if you can set up the
in the videos of the panelists or leo
eldar
daniel upon